- Hi, everyone.
I'm Carolina.
I love everything movies, I
love everything pop culture,
and I'm the type of person
that when I watch movies,
I look at a kitchen and I go ugh,
I wish that was my kitchen.
Specifically, Nancy Meyer kitchens, okay?
So today, we're gonna
be taking this kitchen
and we're gonna be
transforming it into the style
of three of my favorite movies.
One, of course, being a Nancy
Meyers film, It's Complicated.
The second being Amelie,
and the third, Howl's Moving Castle.
Now listen, I can't decorate
this space by myself.
Luckily, we have an amazing
group of women today,
we have Alyssa and Claire on the art team,
they're gonna be transforming this space,
and I can't wait to
see what it looks like.
Now let's get to our first kitchen.
Nancy Meyers, I hope I make you proud.
(clapboard snapping)
So the first kitchen we have today
is inspired by the movie It's Complicated.
It is a 2009 film by Nancy
Meyers starring Meryl Streep,
Alec Baldwin, Steve Martin.
A great cast of people, dare I say?
So when I first heard we
were doing a video like this,
I immediately thought we have
to do Nancy Meyers kitchen,
hello?
That's the best parts of
her films are her sets,
her kitchens, and allegedly,
her own kitchen is quite
beautiful and spectacular.
Nancy, please invite me over
so I can verify that statement.
But it was one of those movies
that was on HBO all the time,
so when my mom would watch it,
I would just sit and watch it with her.
I was way too young,
way too young to be watching this movie.
However, I loved it!
I love Nancy Meyers films so
much, The Parent Trap, hello?
It's the best movie ever,
and this movie in particular,
my favorite scene is when Meryl Streep
is making the chocolate croissants.
My mom and I talk about that scene a lot,
we've even attempted to
make chocolate croissants
and it just was not up to par.
Everything here in the
kitchen, for the most part,
is pretty neutral.
The movie is set in Santa Barbara
so this aesthetic is the
coastal grandmother aesthetic.
You might've remembered it
as being a TikTok trend,
people were calling it also
the Nancy Meyers aesthetic.
Flowy white T-shirts,
some not so skinny jeans,
maybe some of those new cute mini Uggs,
you know what I'm talking about?
You know maybe you're
drinking your hot coffee
or your hot chocolate and you're
looking out onto your beach
and you're just like
contemplating your life,
that's the kind of aesthetic
we were going for today.
So contrary to the
title, It's Complicated,
and the messy love triangle
that we see in the film,
the kitchen is not complicated.
It's very clean, it's very
much where Meryl Streep
has full control of her life,
whereas everywhere else,
she kinda does not. (laughs)
This kitchen in particular,
has everything a baker/chef
needs within reach.
The food is all on display,
it's in glass coverings,
it's in eyesight so you
know you're in a very good,
ready to eat kitchen.
So it's a lot of rattan vibe.
Now, as much as I love
a good coastal kitchen,
it's time to swipe this kitchen away,
and into the world of a fun,
Parisian Amelie kitchen.
(clapboard snapping)
Bienvenue to Amelie's kitchen!
Who can forget that iconic scene
of her in the movie theater
where she's just looking
straight into the camera,
and then she looks back at the people?
Amelie is a movie that has left
such a huge impact in my life.
I feel like it's an animated
film for some reason,
that's what it comes across.
And the colors!
I mean who could forget the colors?
The colors are so unique.
The greens, the reds, the yellows,
and they're all inspired by paintings
of Brazilian artist, Juarez Machado.
Now, the character of Amelie is someone
who doesn't really need lavish things.
All of her decor is very
simple, it's very traditional,
she likes to bake so we have things
that are easy access to bake.
Now, the clock is such an
important motif in the film
because the narrator, whenever
he narrates something,
there's always a specific time attached
to whatever is going on.
So it's smack dab in the
center of the kitchen.
Now in the film Amelie, she
has a windowsill of plants
and herbs so she can spy on
her neighbors, like I do also,
and we paid homage to that
with these little plants
at the edge of the sink.
Now, Amelie also has a cat,
if you remember the scene
where she thinks her lover
is gonna come through the
beaded doorway and it's the cat,
and I also have a cat.
So we paid homage to the
cats by having the paintings
and the little statue above the microwave.
Now, Amelie loves to
bring joy to strangers
with the gnome in the film,
so we also have our own little gnome
that'll bring joy every
time we enter the kitchen.
Now this kitchen, like the film,
is all about the little details,
specifically in the coloring
with the red and the greens
like I mentioned before.
So we have red tables, we
have green and red utensils,
some mugs, and to bring out some texture,
we have some checkered things as well.
And I mean this table is so
cute and it's so reminiscent
of the tables of the
cafe where Amelie works.
Now, as much as I love this kitchen,
it's time to say au revoir to Montmartre
and hello to Miyazaki.
(clapboard snapping)
Now last but certainly not least,
is the recreation of Howl's
Moving Castle in kitchen form.
Now, I am so excited
about this transformation,
specifically because Studio Ghibli films
have left such a huge impact on my life,
especially Howl's Moving Castle.
This is just very earthy, it
feels kinda human, if you will,
with the heart right
there, very cluttered.
And it is very cluttered at
the beginning of the film
until Sophie comes and
cleans it all up for him.
So the kitchen is inside a
really weird, big moving castle,
hence the title, Howl's Moving Castle,
and so it's very much
human, it's very cluttered.
If the house is moving,
things are gonna shift,
things are gonna be messy,
and if you've seen the film,
you're probably like wait,
I know that little plate back there.
So this plate is a callback
to the portal door situation
in Howl's Moving Castle where
he gets to different places,
if you will.
So it's a painted plate
as a callback to that,
how cute is that?
One really awesome thing
about Studio Ghibli movies
is the food.
The ASMR food I think is an aspect
in every single film of his.
When Sophie first enters the
castle, there's food everywhere
because they can't
really cook without Howl
telling Calcifer what to
do, but Sophie's like no,
I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna
boss Calcifer around.
Now, one of my favorite
scenes in Howl's Moving Castle
is when Howl gets mad at Sophie
'cause she messes with his potions
so he picks the wrong one
and his hair changes color,
and I like when Howl
has his dark hair, okay?
So as an ode to all the
magic potions in the castle,
we have the little bottles
right here, super cute.
What feels so special
about this kitchen is,
within a moving castle, it's
very human, it's very DIY,
it's not immaculate, it's not clean.
Like humans, it's messy.
(clapboard snapping)
And there you have it!
That was such an
incredible transformation.
Comment below which of the transformations
was your favorite, and which
of your favorite movies
has the best kitchen,
and maybe we'll get to do it next time?
(dinging effect)
Thanks for watching, bye!
(upbeat music)